Hogwarts Legacy has provided us with yet
another update on the game just here
before the Thanksgiving holidays in the
US and it actually did not come in the
form of the Fall ASMR which we are still
expecting very soon as well instead this
came in the form of a brand new
character card I guess that's what we're
gonna have to start calling these things
at this point because they are no longer
limited to just students or companions
because now we have Professor Dinah
heckett the defense against the dark
arts professor of house Ravenclaw now up
until this point we did already know the
last name was heckett although today it
was finally revealed the official
correct pronunciation thanks to
community manager Chandler wood and we
also know that she is the defense
against the dark arts Professor but now
we learned that she is also of house
Ravenclaw as indicated by the icon here
above her head on the character card
additionally we got the following bio
the stern but likable Professor heckett
takes her teaching responsibilities
quite seriously after a successful
career with the ministry of magic during
which she is rumored to have spent time
in the department of mysteries she
retired to become hogwarts's defense
against the dark arts Professor though
she is happy to be at Hogwarts some
believe her Hands-On teaching method
satiates an innate desire for Action so
there we have it yet another Hogwarts
Legacy Professor who is confirmed to
have worked for the ministry of magic if
you remember before we also learned that
our potions Master Professor sharp is a
former auror so that makes two now who
have previously worked for the ministry
of magic and even more intriguing with
Professor heckett is the fact that she
spent time in the department of
mysteries and this is something that
Hogwarts Legacy indicated we are going
to find out more about in the final game
in a response to Prof Lynette or wizard
PhD over on Twitter Hogwarts Legacy
responded perhaps you will learn more
about her time at the ministry dot dot
dot I also love the fact that they place
a focus on her Hands-On teaching style
if you remember in Harry Potter and the
Order of the Phoenix much to the
annoyance of the students there at
Hogwarts Dolores Umbridge of course was
horrible in so many ways but one of the
most frustrating things about her was
that she would only teach magical Theory
and did not want the students to
actually practice against dark magic
Professor heckett on the other hand
seems to be the exact opposite of that
I'm almost getting a little bit of a
mad-eye moody vibe from her here and
again I guess that would be fake Moody
because it wasn't actually Moody
teaching Harry it's always weird every
time I think about it now in another
Twitter reply Hogwarts Legacy teased
that even more of these character cards
are coming with more professors in a
reply to Wes Nemo over on Twitter they
said she is not the only Professor
you'll be introduced to so which
Professor do you guys want to hear more
about next let me know in the comments
below and once again we do know that she
is Ravenclaw but there was also some big
news revealed recently about the
Ravenclaw companion classmate we're
still not really sure what to make of
that I had a whole video breaking it
down here on the right side of your
screen so check that one out next as
always thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon